[Musique]
la côte caribéenne colombienne
elle s'étend sur plus de 1500
km de la frontière du Panama jusqu'à du
[Musique]
Venezuela des plages de sable blanc une
biodiversité unique la troisème plus
grande barrière de corail au
[Musique]
monde les cultures afroolombiennes
antillais et indigènes aux populations
espagnoles la société caribéenne est
aujourd'hui reconnue comme l'une des
plus diverses de la planète
[Musique]
oubliez la violence des cartels de
drogue la région attire aujourd'hui les
visiteurs du monde
entier
des villes coloniales aux descendants
d'esclaves évadés de palenk nous vous
proposons d'embarquer pour un voyage à
la rencontre de ces peuples colombiens
des
Caraïbes nous commençons notre voyage au
beau milieu de l'océan dans l'archipel
de s
Bernardo
[Musique]
l'un des plus beaux paysages au monde 10
îles paradisiaques parmi elles Santa
Cruz delis lot 1200 habitants concentrés
sur un hectare à peine plus grand qu'un
terrain de football ce qui fait d'elle
une des îles les plus densément peuplé
au
monde l'île est artificielle elle a été
construite avec des amas de pierre et
des blocs de béton une centaine
d'habitations sur un espace si réduit
que la construction se prolonge
aujourd'hui sur la
mer toutes les familles de lî vivent
exclusivement de la pêche
poonneorigine
de il ébl des de fortune pour passer la
nuit C il y a un
siècle au début il ét seulement une
poignée puis petit à petit d'autres
pêcheurs les ont rejoint et l' beaucoup
agrandie
il y a eu de plus en plus de monde sur
l'île ils ont un secret pour attirer les
poissons transmis par leur
grand-père ça c'est un Caracol on
utilise ce coquillage
comme
quce qu' est gros
[Musique]
celui-là bon maintenant on va ramener le
poisson pour cuisiner le repas de ce
midi à la
maison on en a pêché une douzaine ce
midi
Jorg Luis habite avec sa femme Maria et
ses enfants dans ce petit
cabanon la nourriture est transportée
par bateau depuis Carthagène une à deux
fois par
[Applaudissements]
mois
on va bientôt pouvoir manger sur l'île
tout dépend de
l'essence chaque jour il faut que l'on
en trouve pour nos bateaux de
pêcheci je avec mes enfants et mes
petits
enfants et ça me rend
heureuseécomie de l Est la pêche mais le
tourisme commence à se développer aux
alentours sur l'île l'eau de pluie est
recyclée l'électricité est générée par
ces immenses panneaux
solaires Anderson est né ici il n'a
jamais quitté son
[Musique]
île
voici ma mère ma et mes
neveux tellement petit qu'on doit tout
partager on doit penser aux autres
constamment
[Musique]
ça
de
enfants là c'est le PA et derrière c'est
la
cuisine chaque petite parcelle est
occupée nous on a ce petit espace ici
c'est notre petite cour et on y stock
les bateaux et les
animaux
il y a tellement de monde qui vit à la
maison que nous sommes obligés de tout
organiser
méticuleusement le linge les
lit la cuisine tout doit être bien
planifié j'ai 21 petits enfants qui
vivent avec moi même si parfois c'est
difficile je suis très
heureusez viens sors de l'eau
[Musique]
à la nuit tombée Anderson et les
habitants de lî se retrouvent pour
chanter de la
champette un genre musical dont les
racines remontent aux années 70 quand
des marins de caragène retournai sur les
côtes avec dans les C des dis de
[Musique]
[Rires]
afain la champette c'est une musique qui
vient
d'Afrique et aujourd'hui on l'a
réinventé
[Musique]
avec
on parle de notre quotidien de nos
aventures de tous les
jour par exemple quand on est dans un
bar avec des amis et qu'on se raconte
des histoires on s'en inspire pour
improviser une
chanson
[Musique]
chiffre étonnant la moitié des habitants
de Lille sont des enfants comme tous les
jeunes du pays il s'identif au grandar
nationale de
footall comme l' est trop petite pour
accueillir un terrain ils ont l'habitude
de se rendre sur un voisin complètement
inhabité mais il a de la place pour
[Musique]
jouer laisse-moi mettre mes
crampons
bon vous êtes combien les
garçons
comptezv 5 bon on va bientôt commencer à
[Musique]
jouer dans une équipe et dans
l'autre et un footall nouveau
genreé ici on a cré ce que l'on appelle
le microotall car on n pas la place
d'avoir vrai terrain de
foot du coup on joue toujours à 5 contre
5 ans il s'entraîne tous les
weekends
moi si je veux devenir footballeur c'est
pour sortir mes parents de la pauvreté
aider les autres de l qui ont besoin
d'argent et ach mes propres
choses ici depuis qu'on est petit on
s'entide et on doit continuer comme
ça
[Musique]
Mo j'adore
VI c'est vraiment super
icizante pour
nous no debía
invitarme pero ahí comprendí lo que era
el
amor por eso yo me conseguí
otray de Maica y en
detalle no te preocupes que aquí detalle
esto se pega aquí vamos bajarle vamos
zumbarle vamos parao para que suene ba
vamos bajarle vamos zumbarle
nous continuons notre voyage à la
découverte de la perle des Caraïbes la
séduisante
carthagiène ville fortifiée construite
au milieu du 16e siècle par les
[Musique]
Espagnols
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plus d'un tiers des habitants sont des
afroolombiens des descendants
[Musique]
d'esclaves
la ville et son métissage ont
aujourd'hui un visage le voici peint sur
les murs comme un
[Musique]
symbole ce visage c'est celui d'Anna
Lisa célèbre mannequin engagé pour
défendre la cause des femme noir de
Carthagène c'est un artiste irlandais
qui a peint Anna Lisa son visage a
depuis fait le tour de la
Colombie il m'a représenté sous trois
profils
distins la blanche
colonisatrice l'afro et
l'indigène le peintre les a dessiné pour
rappeler que toutes ces femmes ont dû se
battre pour préserver leurs espaces et
leurs territoires c'est pour cela qu'il
les a appelé les trois guerrières mais
la lutte doit continuer pour ne plus
jamais qu'on nous réduise en esclavage
et queon prne notre
[Musique]
le quartier de gsemmanie a été le
théâtre de la révolte contre les
colonisateurs
espagnols ces habitants ont marché
jusqu'au palais du gouvernement pour
l'indépendance
ils ont fini par l'obtenir le 11
novembre
1811 l'esprit frondeur et contestataire
est encore en eux aujourd'hui il se
devine sur les murs et les
façades les peintures urbaines sont un
moyen d'expression elles ont fini par
gagner leur lettrre de
noblesse certaines de ces œuvres sont
reconnu dans le monde
entier
bonjour Un j d'or s'il vous
plaît que pensezvous du changement de ce
quartier c'est beaucoup plus joli
aujourd'hui les choses sont différentes
j'ai plus de travail par
exemple avant cétait tout délabré mais
désormais les touristes viennent ici
pour voir les graffiti on dit même que
c'est le meilleur quartier à visiter de
tout
caragenne
pour moi ce quartier est un symbole de
résistance on a utilisé ici l'espace
public pour en faire un lieu de création
artistique comme si le quartier était un
grand tableau
blanc si fuera un cuadro en
blanco sur les murs de K c'est peindre
notre
réalité Anna luouisa se bat pour
entretenir la mémoire de ses ancêtres
esclaves l'exploitation de leur force de
travail a permis à la ville de devenir
au 16e siècle un des plus grands ports
de l'empire espagnol et le centre
économique de toute la mer des
Caraïbes
les esclaves ont payé le prix fort ils
travaillaient jour et nuit dans les
champs de canne à sucre parqué dans des
hangars torturé parfois jusqu'à la mort
quand il ne travaillaient pas àe vite ou
lorsqu'il tentaient de s'enfuir au fil
des siècles la ville est devenue le
principal port négrié d'Amérique des
centaines de milliers d'esclaves sont
arrivés ici par
bateau
l'architecture est aujourd'hui un
héritage de cette période coloniale
cette page de l'histoire ravierre
cassiani la connaît sur le bout des
doigts chaque recoin chaque Ruel emporte
les
traces
salut comment allez-vous qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est un bonbon à la
papaille dans ce marché du centre-eville
aujourd'hui réputé pour ces confiseries
200000 esclaves ont été
vendus vous saviez qu'on vendait des
esclaves ici avant oui ils étaient
vendus ici même on m'a raconté cette
histoire
heureusement qu'aujourd'hui on y vend
plus que des
desserts ah oui je suis bien
d'accord les esclaves travaillaient dans
la culture de can à sucre mais pas
seulement il en avait aussi dans
l'ingénierie la construction la
recherche de pierres précieuses il ne
s'agissait pas seulement de faire venir
de la force de travail mais aussi
différents
savoirfa c'est ce mélange qui a forgé
aujourd'hui l'identité des afrescend
[Musique]
c'est délicieux merci
beaucoup Carthagène est fier de posséder
l'un des systèmes les plus complets de
fortification militaire d'Amérique du
Sud là vous êtes sur la muraille de la
ville dans le quartier de Santo Domingo
protégé à l'intérieur il y a Carthagène
et en face la mer des
Caraïbes les pierres ont été extraites
taillé puis mis entre les mains des
esclaves venus d'Afrique pour construire
la
muraille les esclaves qui arrivaient à
caragène ne restaient pas tous
là beaucoup étaient envoyé dans les
autres colonies comme l'Équateur le
Mexique et aussi en Amérique
les afroocaribéens subissent encore les
retombées de leur tragique histoire une
majorité vit dans les Cartier
périphérique et défavorisé de Carthagène
là où un habitant sur TR vit en dessous
du seuil de
[Musique]
pauvreté
on doit faire un
cercle encore une
fois tu peux me faire un nouveau rythme
s'il te
plaîtopilo est né ici
il a monté cette école de danse
africaine pour tenter de redonner un
projet d'avenir à une jeunesse
déscolarisée ici c'est comme une grande
famille moi je suis le papa et elle ce
sont toutes mes
femmes cette école de danse c'est une
belle opportunité pour que les jeunes
s'en sortent dans la vie et qu'ils
puissent peut-être un jour réaliser leur
rêve etzv les pieds
[Musique]
Valéria est née ici cela fait déjà 2 ans
qu'elle fait partie de l'école elle rêve
de devenir danseuse professionnelle avec
un style bien à elle un mélange de danse
africaine et
contemporaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand je danse je dénonce la
prostitution infantile et les violences
que subissent les petites filles et les
petits garçons dans notre pays je me
sens plus libre depuis que je
danse j'espère pouvoir réussir à nous
sortir de cette misère ma moi grâce à ce
que je
fais c'est ça mon rêve dans la
[Musique]
vie les tambours c'est la force
africaine c'est ce qui donne la
virtuosité dans le
mouvement dans quelques heures Valéria
va présenter pour la toute première fois
sa chorégraphie au centre culturel de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Carthagène
comment tu vas mon amour tu es
contente aujourd'hui c'est le grand
jour allez va dans la salle de bain te
changer
elle vit avec sa mère Maria dans cette
modeste
maison père Val ne vit pas avec nous
depuis qu'elle a rencontré le professeur
thophilo et intégré la troupe de danse
tout a changé chez ma fille elle est
beaucoup plus heureuse en
paix même au collège elle a des
meilleures
notes ce soir je veux montrer le
meilleur de moi-même tout ce que
thophilo m'a
appris c'est aussi l'occasion de sortir
avec ma maman et de se promener passer
du bon temps
ensemble et surtout
danser la famille va découvrir les beaux
quartiers de Carthagène où restaurant
musé et galeries se sont
[Musique]
multiplié
c'est la première fois que je viens
ici c'est très
grand comme c'est
beau ça va tu te sens
[Musique]
prête
laasp aféne don nous faisons
partie il permet d'affirmer notre place
partout dans la ville et de nous donner
une reconnaissance aux yeux des autres
habitants pu une symbolique très forte
car cette salle cétait le palais de
l'inquis présenter sa chorégraphie plus
mort que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vivant le public est composé d'acteurs
du monde culturel metteur en scène
chorégraphe espère être repéré ce soir
par l'un d'entre
eux sa chorégraphie ce qu'elle fait ce
n'est pas que de la danse c'est de la
reconstruction sociale elle a tellement
d'impact les gens comme nous qui la voit
danser vous repartir avec beaucoup plus
que de la danse en
tête
[Applaudissements]
je suis tellement fière
d'elle c'est tellement beau quand elle
se
produit je suis tellement fière de toi
je t'aime tellement mon
amour
[Musique]
l'héritage africain est bien vivant à 60
km au pied des montagnes il existe une
ville où il est visible et palpable un
village
diréductible symbole de résistance et de
liberté niché au pied des montagnes som
Basilio des palanqu fondé au 17e siècle
par des esclaves en
[Musique]
fuite originaire de Guiné Bissao du
Congo du Sénégal ou du Nigéria ces
pionniers ont fondé le premier Palenqué
le premier village fortifié de
l'histoire
[Musique]
latino-américaine le temps semble s'être
arrêté pendant quat siècles les
paleneros ont vécu coup du monde une
autarciie salvatrice puisque leur
culture africaine et leurs traditions
ont été
[Musique]
préservé parmi ces traditions la
surprenante pratique de la boxe anglaise
les jeunes du village s'entraînent tous
les jours dans ce
hangar vas-y douement pas de mouvement
sans
réfléchir Pedro Salina est né à Palen
c'est un entraîneur heureux car tout le
monde ici veut faire de la
boxe
on est devenu une référence quand tu
viens de Palen tu dois être fort si tu
te B en compétition et que tu es d'ici
alors tu n'as pas le choix tu do être
plus fort que les autres voilà
tout on est le seul village qui a TR
champions mondiaux de
box et parmi eu le plus grand de tous
les temps s'appelle k
p il est resté 8 ans champion du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monde antioant de son vrai nom le boxur
de légende de la
Colombie originaire
deierombien Chion monde de
box
et qu'il a défendu 21 fois un palmarè
exceptionnel un héros
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
national depuis cette petite salle de
boxe est devenue une fabrique à champion
des boxs en her comme Manu se prépare
pour les championnats
régionaux
il faut que l'on continue de montrer que
s Basilio de Palen V à travers nous on
est en train de poursuivre ce que K P a
semé on veut tous être des champions du
monde comme lui et faire connaître s
Basilio de Palen au monde
entier
les esclaves se sont échappé ils nont
cessé de se battre pour conserver leur
liberté le lutte s transformé en un
sport on a cette combattivité enraciné
en nous et aujourd'hui elle s'exprime
par la
boxe
[Musique]
leur combat pour la liberté a commencé
au début du 17e siècle à la tête de la
révolte Domingo bioyo un roi africain
réduit en esclavage par les colons
espagnols dans les champs de canne à
sucre il monte une armée de fugitif
cette communauté Maronne devient si
puissante que la monarchie espagnole
finit par lui accorder
conditionelle C de s'agrandir et lui
prête forte en cas de
besoedro l'entraîneur de box habite
encore dans la maison de ses arrièr
grands-parents bonjour bienvenue chez
moi je vous présente ma
famille ici je vis qu'avec des
femmes
elle c'est ma petite
cadette comme toutes les femmes du
village Jana et sa petite fille se TR
des nates c'est la coiffure des anciens
esclaves une coiffure qui renfermait
bien des
secrets la coiffure des femmes servait
de carte pour montrer le chemin de la
liberté au peuple de Saint Basilio des
Palen pendant
l'esclavage c'est les chemins qui
indiquaient par quel endroit on pouvait
passer et ceux qu'il fallait éviter pour
s'enfuir disons que ça c'était la
plantation là il y avait la maison on
savait que devant il y avait des gardes
donc ici on fait une trisse pour
indiquer que la maison était là et que
ça c'est le chemin par lequel sortir tu
vois ces ondulations servaient à
symboliser les endroits où l'on pouvait
trouver des cultures parce qu'une fois
qu'ils étaient libre il fallait bien
qu'ils se nourrissent les autres
esclaves qui s'étaient évadés leur
laissai même des allumettes parfois pour
cu
c'est important pour nous de conserver
cette manière de nous coiffer parce que
même si on est dans un monde de plus en
plus globalisé nous on veut préserver
notre mode de vie et ça se traduit aussi
à travers nos
cheveux nos hemos enmarcado tanto en
esto la globalización que hemos perdido
la esencia es nuestro
[Musique]
cab
alors il paraî que tu veux te battre
contre
moi
toi tu n'auras pas le courage de monter
sur le
ring ici on parle très fort mais on n
pas du tout en train de s'embrouiller
c'est notre manière d'exprimer notre
point de vue en criant parfois ça ne
finit jamais en
[Musique]
bagarre
cette joie de vivre et cette culture si
particulière attirent aujourd'hui les
visiteurs du monde entier depuis 30 ans
chaque année au mois d'octobre a lieu le
festival de
Pal mode musique tambours et champs
africains pendant 5 jours les habitants
de la ville célèbrent leur culture
afroolombienne les touristes viennent de
tout le continent pour y assister ce
groupe arrive du
Pérou ici à PAL je suis très connu
savez-vous combien de gamins j'ai formé
à la boxe et qui sont célèbres
aujourd'hui dans le
monde un
nbreini je par 20000 que personne
n'arrive à lui toucher la tête pendant
une minute moi je veux
essayer je veux essayer de lui toucher
la
tête
tiens je t'offre un
ver ah ça y est j'ai
gagné j'ai réussi en faire
deux il y a tellement de gens qui
viennent ici pendant le
festival fait une moyenne à l'année
c'est comme si nous recevions plus de
1000 personnes tous les mois on a
beaucoup de choses à moner au et le
monde entier est curieux de découvrir
tout
ça le soir venu s Basilio des PAL se
métamorphose la musique envah les ru
tourist et habitants se mélang sur les
rythmes
[Musique]
afrolombiens
allez on y va il faut se
dépêcher dans cette école de danse les
élèves apprennent des rythmes africains
après une année de travail ils
s'apprêtent à présenter leur
spectacle c'est très important car c'est
la plus grande manifestation culturelle
de notre village il danse le lumbalou un
rythme qui célèbre le passage de la vie
à la
[Musique]
mort le tambour est fabriqué avec du
cuir de chèvre
et la base est faite avec un Tron entier
que l'on creuse comme
ça on l'utilise pour les danses
traditionnel mais aussi pour les
cérémonies
[Musique]
funéraires dans cette danse on parle de
l'histoire de Catalina algongo c'était
une jeune femme symbole de Saint Basilio
des Palen elle adoré danser et elle a
disparu nous sommes vraiment dans
l'Afrique colombienne l'école de danse
enseigne aux jeunes élèves les
traditions musicales du Congo rapporté
d'Afrique de l'Ouest par les
[Musique]
esclaves ce soir c'est la première fois
que Rous a joué sur
[Musique]
pour moi c'est beaucoup de joie et
d'émotion car je vais accomplir mon
rêve j'ai toujours voulu jouer du
tambour j'ai pratiqué tous les jours et
maintenant je sais jouer comme
[Applaudissements]
eux j'ai commencé à l'âge de 5 ans en
regardant ces Gal jou et en les écoutant
attentivement
[Musique]
ciao ce soir j'espère que tout le monde
va pouvoir sentir l'âme du festival de
tambour de sint Basilio de
Palen et Lili ouvr le
[Musique]
festival
ad
[Musique]
VI cat y Noos
excellent le festival de tambour c'est
bien plus qu'un spectacle c'est une
vitrine pour nous les jeunes de San
Basilio des Palen c'est la manifestation
de notre culture on a besoin
d'événements comme celui-ci pour
continuer à entretenir et écrire notre
histoireas des PAL est aujourd'huicrit
patrimoine immatériel de l'humanité pour
les habitants c'est une victoire à la
fois culturelle et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
politique
[Musique]
oo
comme le veut la tradition le festival
de Palen s'achève par une célébration
face au lever du
soleil suivons notre voyage Cap sur
Santa Cruz de montpox à 250 km en
bordure du plus grand fleuve du pays le
rio
[Musique]
Magdalena pendant la conquête espagnole
tout le commerce transitait par ce
fleuve la ville était un comptoir
économique son quartier colonial l'un
des mieux préservés du pays témoigne de
son âge d'or
[Musique]
ici la population est métissée composée
de descendants de colons espagnol
d'indigènes et
d'Africains
[Musique]
c'est dans cette région reculée AB et
ses
[Applaudissements]
amis
[Musique]
les esclaves jouaient beaucoup de
musique quand les colons les
transféraient sur le fleuve les esclaves
ramenaient avec eux ses tambours et ses
flutes
[Musique]
indigènes Rio Magdalena était
l'épicentre du commerce de toute la
région c'est pour cela que monpox est
une ville importante depuis sa création
il y a plus de 400
ans à l'époque des milliers d'esclaves
arrivaient sur ces
bateaux parmi eux les ancêtrre
d'Ignacio
[Musique]
je me sens plus africain car c'est un
peuple travailleur qui a tout fait pour
évoluer et
grandir les Africains ils ont toujours
poursuivi leur quête de liberté face au
colonisateurs c'est pour cela que je me
sens
africain
[Musique]
chaque bateau arrivé sur le fleuve en
musique donc t leurs déplacement les
esclaves jou ses rythmes les
propriétaires les laissai faire car ils
aimaient bien et pour nous aujourd'hui
c'est important de continuer à faire
[Musique]
ça
monpox a été la première ville libérée
de la colonisation espagnole c'était le
6 août 1810
à la tête de la révolte Simon Bolivard
le général vénézuélien vénéré dans la
région il est surnommé le Libertador le
libérateur depuis les habitants vivent
hors du temps il continuent de perpétuer
les
traditions
[Applaudissements]
Abel vit dans cette maison avec ses 10
petits enfants musicien professionnel il
transmet sa passion à toute sa
[Musique]
famille
voici mon épouse cela fait 30 ans que
nous sommes
ensemble je fais des confitures pour
faire tourner l'économie de la maison
dans notre ville il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'entreprises ou de magasins qui
embuch vous savez c'est pas évident de
gagner de l'argent
ici avant l'arrivée des Espagnols il y a
4 siècles montpox était peuplé d'Indiens
les T premiers habitants de la côte
caraïbe la culture musicale de la ville
est à l'image de cette histoire Abel et
son fils jouent de la gaita cette flû
indigène tiens essaie de refaire le
rythme sa conception est unique taillée
dans un cœur de cactus elle renferme une
plume de canard utilisé durant les
célébrations religieuses autochtones ses
sonorités les champs des
[Musique]
oiseaux ici on est en recherche
perpétuelle de nos
origines les rythmes Espagnols les
sonorités africaines ont fait évoluer
les mélodies de la GA qui est devenue
une partie intégrante de la culture
musicale des Caraïbes
[Musique]
colombiennes
dans cette quête de nos origines cette
flute est très importante car comme elle
vient d'une ethnie indigène elle nous
fait sentir que nous sommes aussi
américains indigènes africain et même
espagnol on retrouve ces mélodies dans
la sensubia mélange de dans africaines
et d'instruments
indiges
[Musique]
il est une spécialité à montpox
difficile à découvrir au premier coup
d'œil derrière ces murs travaillent en
silence des artisans joaliers ils sont
les dignes héritiers de l'époque
coloniale celle où l'or et l'argent
étaient entreposés ici avant d'être
envoyés en
[Musique]
Europe ce ir faire les habitants
veillent à
[Musique]
l'entretenir dans cette école les élèves
apprennent l'art du filigrane celui de
tisser des bijoux
délicats josimar est professeur dans cet
établissement depuis pr de
5 il faut que tu mettes bien les petites
parties à
l'intérieur le Fig s'obtient en étirant
les fils d'argent les Arabes igné au
conquist espagnol qui l'ont apporté avec
en Amérique du
[Applaudissements]
Sud vous voyz sures
cré comme celu- pour les transformer en
boucle
d'oreille ces bijoux sont revendus
jusquà 150 dollars pièces selon leur
poids chaque boucle d'oreille chaque
médaillon chaque bracelet est conçu
comme un tableau composé de fil d'argent
décliné à partir d'un modèle de base
chaque pièce est
unique Anderson apprend à faire fondre
le
métal il faut que tu soudes toute cette
pièce que tout soit lisse pour qu'il n'y
ait plus aucun résidu il ne doit plus
rien
rester la création d'un bijou peut
prendre plusieurs
semaines cet artisanat fait partie de
mon histoire et je trouve cela beau de
travailler
[Musique]
l'argent c'est une fierté d'apprendre
cette technique c'est difficile ça
serait vraiment une grande fierté de
retrouver mes bijoux dans les boutiques
de mon pox ici on ne veut pas que nos
tradition se
perd c'est bon c'est
prêt aujourd'hui près de 200 orfèvres
travaillent encore l'argent et l'or
comme le faisai les premiers colons
espagnol la nueva a 95 ans il est l'un
d'entre eux le doyen toujours en
exercice bon les jeunes je vous présente
le plus vieux maître d'orfèvrerie de
monpox vous allez donc pouvoir échanger
avec quelqu'un qui a de
l'expérience vous pouvez lui poser
toutes les questions que vous
voulez vous devez être des ingénieurs du
filigran vous devez pratiquer tous les
jours pour arriver faire une
figurine vous allez être des génies et
vous devez l'être parce que vous aimez
ça moi
j'adore c'est quelqu'un de votre famille
qui vous a appris la
technique j'ai presque tout appris tout
seul quand j'étais jeune j'ai rencontré
un maître
d'or
je n'arrêtais pas de le regarder et un
jour il m'a dit prends les instruments
et débrouille-toi Simon V la nueva a
appris ce métier dans les années 80
alors que la Colombie traversait une
grave crise
économique la ville avait trois choses
son histoire sa Semaine sainte et l'art
du
filigran c'est pour ça que je vous le
dis les enfants il faut que vous vous
accrochiez
vous avez le monde entre vos
mains je ne vais jamais réussir à lui
ressembler car lui c'est vraiment un
maître ni même à faire des pièces aussi
belles j'aimerais vraiment me rapprocher
le plus possible de ce qu'il fait car
c'est très
beau per
fait
c'est toute ma
vie j'aime tellement le
filigrane je crois que j'aime ça plus
que ma propre
vie cette tradition a permis à monpx
d'être classé au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Abel le musicien répète avec
sa troupe créée il y a 10
[Musique]
ans
aujourd'hui nous allons jouer la danse
des paysans c'est un hommage à tous les
travailleurs des champs de Mompox les
indigènes les Africains et les
ESP la la
la troupe s'entraîne pour le défilé du
carnaval de montpox qui aura lieu demain
des festivités qui célèbre
l'indépendance de la
Colombie est
chorép il faut bien bouger les hanches
et surtout
sourire c'est un rythme que les paysans
chantai quand il travaill dans les
champs le don du
courage a 20 ans elle été choisie pour
ouvrir le défil du
carnaval
en enseignant et en transmettant ces
danses aux nouvelles génération on
assure leur survie et celle de notre
[Musique]
culture pendant la semaine du Carnaval
les maisons se transformment en atelier
de couture
la voici nos robe traditionnelle on doit
y ajouter ce voile pour qu'elles a un
peu plus de
poids et de
volume
nous fabriquons des costumes
folclloriques pour faire vivre notre
famille et notre
Mère angélic la mer de Ch V seule les
nuit sont court la semaine qui précède
le carnaval il faut que tout soit prêt
en temps et en
he
[Musique]
voici mon lieu de travail mon atelier de
couture
aujourd'hui c'est elle qui confectionne
les robes de toutes les écoles de danse
de la
ville quand elle m'a dit qu'elle aimait
la danse folklorique qu'elle voulait
danser et porter des costumes j'étais
vraiment
émue J'ai fabriqué ces premières robes
et elle m tellement les
porter en fait c'est comme si ma fille
avait réalisé mon
rêve
quand tuimes la danse ça te
transporte danser ça peut te faire
oublier tous tes
problèmes ça peut te
libérer c'est quelque chose que je ne
peux pas
expliquer non je peux pas l'expliquer
mais c'est vraiment vraiment très
beau
le défilé va commencer dans quelques
heures
igno et sa troupe se prépare et c'est
bien sûr angéica qui a confectionné leur
[Applaudissements]
costume
AFC C
af sontis en petit paysan
africain ils sont habillés en espagnol
mais ils vont danser sur des rythmes
africains ça c'est une machette pour
couper les mauvaises herbes le sac c'est
pour mettre les
graines
et le bâton c'est pour faire les trous
dans le sol pour que la plante
germe la
[Musique]
PL c'est le plus ancien carnaval de
Colombie existe depuis 3 siècles Abel et
son groupe se préparent durant toute
[Musique]
l'année ces énormes têtes en papier
mâché qui émergent parmi les
carnavaliers caricaturent les anciens
[Musique]
maîtres d'autres personn défile comme
les pilandes des RAC les Comè sur les
champs de canne à sucre elles étaient
connues pour leur bavardage et la
dénonciation des pratiques des colons
elles font aujourd'hui partie du
patrimoine historique des
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Caraïbes avec en tête de cortège le
défilé peut
[Musique]
commencer
liber aujourd'hui on fête la liberté des
peuples indigènes et africains c'est une
fête très émouvante on est heureux
d'être libre vive
l'Amérique
[Musique]
notre voyage se poursuit jusqu'à la
région de Sierra Nevada de Santa Marta
la plus haute montagne côtière du monde
elle borde la mer des
[Musique]
Caraïbes à ses pieds le parc de terona
s'étend sur 15000 hectar cette zone a
été le théâtre d'une guerre sanglante
pendant près d'un demi-siècle les forces
révolutionnaires de Colombie les farces
et les paramilitaires se sont entretués
dans cette jungle laissant derrière eux
des milliers de victimes la paix est
revenue il y a 3 ans et les touristes
[Musique]
aussi
c'est un énorme nid de
termite les fourmis que nous avons en
Autriche sont noir et bien plus petit
ici il y a des fourmis à bois comme
celle-ci elle est énorme c'est fascinant
toutes ces
couleurs
comme de nombreux touristes ce couple va
traverser le parc seul et sans
guide en Europe on entend toujours des
histoires sur le niveau de criminalité
qui existerait en Colombie tout le monde
pense que c'est dangereux de venir ici
oui tout le monde connaî l'histoire des
FAR tout a débuté dans les années 60 ils
ont commencé à fournir la drogue aux
États-Unis puis la guerre du narcrafi
ça a vraiment affecté la
Colombie les farces se sont d'abord
présentés comme les défenseurs des
paysans pauvres avant de s'associer au
narcotrafiquant dans les années 80
retranché dans les zones montagneuses
comme la Sierra Nevada la prise d'otage
devient leur arme de
guerre
ingrid betancour est l'une de leur plus
célèbres
prisonnières en novembre 2016 un accord
de paix est signé mettant fin à plus
d'un demisècle de
conflit toute la région renaît
aujourd'hui après 3h de marche le couple
d'Autrichien arrive sur la plage de la
piscina au cœur du parc
terona
on a réussi on l'a
fait c'est fatiguant mais le paysage
récompense tous nos efforts ça vaut
vraiment le coup c'est le
paradis
ça fait du bien l'au n'est pas très
foine mais un petit peu quand même juste
ce qu'il
faut c'est pour moi une des dernières
grandes aventures que la planète a
offrir j'espère que la jeune génération
aura plus d'opportunités grâce au
tourisme qui se développe il y a de plus
en plus d'infrastructures qui sont en
train de se construire il faut qu'ils
arrivent à gérer cette transition et que
le tourisme garde seulement un impact
positif même les villages les plus
reculés se sont retrouvés pris en é
entre les les violences des
paramilitaires et cell des mouvements de
Guera comme ces villageois les indigènes
koogis qui ont bien failli disparaître
leur terre était convoité par les
narcotrafiquants les Kogis sont une des
grandes civilisations précolombiennes du
continent ils étai un demiillion avant
l'arrivée des colons espagnols il ne
serait plus que 12000 aujourd'hui replié
dans les hautes vallées de la Serra
Nevada
[Musique]
plus bas d'autres villages comme celui
de Minka ont choisi quant à eux de
s'ouvrir aux visiteurs étrangers c'est
ici que se retrouve tous ceux qui
explorent la Sira
[Musique]
Nevada depuis l'accord de paix les
auberges poussent comme des champignons
le tourisme se développe et les
étrangers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'install est américaine avec son petit
ami manuel ils ont créé cette école de
langue pour former les
[Musique]
habitants
ce soir je vais vous donner un cours sur
les
directionsun d'entrex n'a pu étudier
l'anglais à
l'école la majorité des investisseurs
sont
étrangers n'apennent pas l'anglais ça va
être difficile pour eux de trouver une
place dans cette nouvelle économie c'est
pour cela que nous avons décidé de créer
cette
école s'ils veulent Touvrir un
établissement
touristique ou organiser des excursions
désormais ils n'auront plus l'obstacle
de la
langue avant l'accord de paix les
habitants n'avaient aucun contact avec
l'extérieur aucune opportunité de parler
l'anglais
je vois souvent des touristes qui
descendent du bus ou qui se baladent je
veux leur parler mais je reste bloqué
parce que je ne peux pas l'autre jour
j'ai rencontré une dame qui était perdue
et je n'ai pas pu l'aider ça m'a fait
tellement mal de ne pouvoir rien faire
c'est pour ça que je veux apprendre
l'anglais vous être super utile ça
arrive souvent que des touristes
demandent leur chemin et vous répondez
sans comprendre je sais pas c'est par
là moi je vends des fruits et des
légumes dans le
village avec mon métier je vois beaucoup
de touristes
passer
je veux apprendre l'anglais pour être
capable de leur parler quand ils
viennent m'acheter des
fruits il va vous falloir de la force et
de la volonté pour continuer à pratiquer
chez vous si vous croisez des touristes
par exemple dans la rue n'hésitez pas à
leur
parler j'espère vous revoir tous la
semaine prochaine pour qu'on puisse
continuer à apprendre ensemble merci
beaucoup c'est bon nous sommes
prêts salut merci à
tous les habitants se remettent tout
doucement des traumatismes du conflit
pendant des décennies ils ont vécu dans
la peur des farques et des
paramilitaires leur mode de vie n'a pas
changé seule la peur
les familles de vivent et travaill dans
ces fermes agricoles cheando c'est
installé chez la famille de manuel il y
a quelques
années les amis Vinent nous aider à
préparer le
repas alors on va préparer un plat
typique de la région en
famille
j'ai demandé à mes amis en Colombie où
se trouvait la montagne la plus proche
ils m'ont tous envoyé à Minka et je suis
tombée amoureuse de l'endroit de son
histoire des gens
d'ici mais oui c'est le plus
important ans et demi plus tard me voici
en train de préparer le
S le S un ragou vu desîle Canarie
espagnole pendant la colonisation c'est
le plat populaire de la
région
[Musique]
on doit préparer la viande les côtes de
porc le
poulet puis on cuisine le Sango avec du
manioc du maïs de la banane
[Musique]
planttin et des herbes que l'on coupe en
tout petits morceau tout ça vient d'ici
la
nada certains souvenirs sont un des
débiles pour la famille de Manuel
pendant le conflit de habitants du hame
sont mors victime de ball
perdu c'était vraiment
traumatisant
de vra barbares des assassin il tu comme
ça gratuitement on pens que c'était fini
qu'on allait
mourir c'était
difficile on commencé à sortir les gens
de chez et prendre leur terre moi à
l'époque j'étais avec mon bébé mon fils
on est resté caché dans la maison
derrière le
lit cette maison est ancienne ces murs
sont très épais 45 cm environ et c'est
ce qui nous a
protégé on est rest ici à attendre que
les choses change et c'est enfin arrivé
heureusement maintenant on peut vivre en
paix
[Musique]
allez venez vous asseoir qu'est-ce que
c'est bon c'est délicieux c'est vraiment
réussi cétait fait avec
amour
l'année qui a suivi la signature de
l'accord de paix 6 millions de touristes
se sont rendus en
Colombie notre voyage se termine au
large à 700 km du littoral sur
l'archipel des îles sint Andress une
réserve mondiale de la biosphère classée
par
l'Unesco
ces 32 km de barrière de corail font
d'elle une des plus longue du
[Musique]
monde plus proche des Antilles d'Haïti
et de la Jamaïque que des terres
colombiennes 70000 colombiens y vivent
pourtant à la croisée des
cultures
[Musique]
combien l'archipel est préservé mais le
tourisme n'en est pas
[Musique]
exclu plusieurs centaines de visiteurs
débarque chaque jour comme ce couple de
Brésiliens
je sais pas si ça va se voir dans ma
vidéo mais la couleur de l'eau c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
incroyable ça c'est la joie vous allez
ressentir maintenant Kevin organise des
tour en bateau pour une vingtaine
d'euros ils vont visiter de de
l'archipel avant de descendre du bateau
vous pouvez enlever vos chaussures s'il
vous
plaît en moins de 10 ans le nombre de
visiteurs a doubléli chnée
il y a des touristes du monde entier qui
viennent ici d'Europe d'Amérique et de
tous les pays d'Amérique latine tout ce
monde que vous voyez c'est comme ça tous
les
jours j'aimerais enregistrer ce moment
pour la vie auss ble j'ai jamais rien vu
d'I beau ça n'existe vraiment nul part
non
non l'eau est tellement chaude j'ai la
sensation d'entrer dans une piscine
chauffée
entr
pisc m
B c'est
fantastique ils sont tout petits on ne
bouge pas et les poissons viennent tout
près de
nous
[Musique]
pe j'ai essayé d'en attraper un mais ils
sont très
rapides il y a une variété d'espèces
incroyablees sur l'archipel les hôtels à
bas prix se sont multipliés les bateaux
et les déchets laissés par les touristes
derrière eux sont aujourd'hui une menace
pour
[Musique]
l'écosystème
historiquement l'archipel a toujours été
très convoité pendant plus de de siècles
les Anglais les Espagnols et même les
Français en revendiquent à tour de rôle
la possession jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
rattaché à la
Colombie San Andr l'île principale a
réussi à garder son authenticité et sa
culture
affroantillaise ici on parle aussi bien
espagnol anglais que
créole
job est un ilen pur souche ici c'est une
véritable star il chante dans le groupe
de r le plus populaire de l'Î et comme
tous les habitants il jongle lui aussi
d'une langue à
[Musique]
l'autre vous avez quoi comme poisson
aujourd'hui ici ce qui est génial c'est
qu'on peut avoir des produits
frais que ce soit des produitson cul à
la ferme ou qu'on pêche en mer c'est
vraiment
frais cux on peut juste les manger on ne
peut pas les vendre car ce sont des
espèces
protégéesch c'est une tradition qui
vient nos
ancêtres les esclaves africains qui ont
été amenés ici par les Espagnols
que Dieu te bénisse mon ami c'est super
on a de la chance de t'avoir toi et ton
[Rires]
poisson
job repartira avec plusieurs kilos de
poisson frais pour seulement une
vingtaine
[Musique]
d'euros il se prépare à recevoir ses
amis pour le déjeuner il vit dans ce
décor de rêve une ferme tropicale c'est
ici qu'il habite avec sa
femme
[Musique]
je vais récupérer des boscos c'est une
sorte de banane
planttin
maintenant je récupère des fruits à
pain tout ça c'est pour cuisiner le
Rondon notre plat
[Musique]
traditionnel test
microoup
avec S amis il y a déjà 20
ans n on fait du saint musque c'est du
biologique c'est fait avec des
sentiments
naturels cette musique c'est
l'illustration de notre
légèreté bon vibration car saz
et c'est ce qu'on essaie d'exprimer dans
notre
[Musique]
musique dans les années 50 pendant la
dictature le gouvernement en place
il
les et l'ESAG devient
Laue les habit c la disparition de leur
identitérotill et de leularité culturell
comme la langue créole et la musique des
mouvs
sépararo Mar en fait
partie ceonaconte
dansanson
ESTs
notre culture notre couleur et nos
origines souvent les gens du continent
veulent nier ce que nous sommes mais
quand tu n'as pas ta propre identité tu
peux te perdre nous on sait qui on est
et on le revendique en
[Musique]
chanson le random qu'il prépare c'est le
plat des esclaves transmis de génération
en génération la gardienne de la recette
celle qu' l'a transmise à son Petitfils
c'est la grand-mère de
[Musique]
Job ce plat typique se cuisine avec du
poisson des fruits de mer avec des
bananes
plantains et du manioc et tout ça va
mijeté dans du lait de
coco
et ça c'est le
Rondon c'est devenu le plat de toute une
communauté celle des RAL des
[Musique]
afrotill ici nous n'avons pas de farine
mais le fruit à c'est notre à
nous
tout est traditionnel
ici même la façon d'allumer le feu
onutilise pas de kérosène pas d'essence
tout est
naturel tout est fait maison même le
lait de coco la noix été séché puis
râpé
[Musique]
I Je par c'est ça mon langage je
m'identifie à l'Afrique donc je parle la
langue des Africains qui étai
[Musique]
ici ma grand-mère ador cuisiner ce plat
elle mangé tous les jours
très
forte Notre culture c'est celle des
Caraïbes il n'y a aucun doute
làdessus ce sont de multiples influences
qui r sonress si spécial et si
belle nous avons des origines
indigènes mais nous sommes aussi le
fruit de la colonisation anglaise
espagnol et maintenant
colombienne de culture produit un goût
délicieux un AR léger
[Musique]
etûte
l'identité afroaribéenne est en train de
devenir une véritable marque de fabrique
depuis 2 ans il existe même une chaîne
de télévision qui lui est spécialement
dédié Marvin l'ami de Job est l'un des
présentateurs
vedette c'est vraiment important parce
que nous sommes très loin du continent
donc cette chaîne nous permet d'avoir un
contact avec le reste du
monde et puis le reste du monde peut
rester en contact avec nous et savoir ce
qu'il se passe sur
l'île annie est originaire de
Providencia une des îles de l'archipel
depuis 2 ans elle présente cette
émission de
mode aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer un
Nau
style une nouvelle façon de coiffer vos
cheveux ou comment dresser vos boucles
avec de la
mousse regardons le
[Musique]
résultat ici on parle de la beauté
afrocaribéenne c'est vraiment quelque
chose de spécial nous réunissons les
tendances des îles des Caraïb que ce
soit celle de la Jamaïque des Antilles
ou des autres
territoires notre manière d'être notre
joie de vivre nos différents styles de
coiffure avec des couleurs de cheveux
originales c'est vraiment propre à notre
identité caribéenne c'est ça qui nous
différencie et c'est ça qui nous lie
entre peuple des
Caraïbes on revient dans quelques
instants merci à
tous sur cette île d'à peine 50 km de
long règne une ambiance toute jamaïcaine
très décontracté avec forcément du
soleil toute
[Musique]
l'année au bord des routes les bars à
musique réé se succèdent les habitants
qui passent après leur journée de
travail le bar préféré d'anille c'est
celui de dixio un Petitfils d'immigré
jamaïcain
[Musique]
có oh oh
je suis super contente de te
voir c'est dans les années 60 pendant
les débuts du réga en Jamaïque que ce
style musical est arrivé
jusqu'ici le reg a été importé sur l'île
par des pêcheurs et des marins ils
amenaient des viniles de Jamaïque et de
différents endroits des
Caraïbes prier courant musical ici mais
on avait aussi d'autres genres du Suk
Soka du calypso aussi tu peux aller dans
n'importe quelle des Caraïbes même sur
la côte colombienne tu trouveras
toujours un bar de c'est le symbole de
notre vie
[Musique]
relax
dans quelques heures job et son groupe
vont jouer au Green Moon Festival toute
la ville est là et même les habitants
des îles voisines ont fait le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
déplacement
de nombreux artistes reprennent les
genres traditionnels de la région le zou
et bien sûr le
[Musique]
réger Annie la présentatrice est là
aussi toute la soirée sera retransmise
en direct sur la télévision locale
cet événement c'est comme une plateforme
pour connecter toutes les populations
afrocaribéennes on a des groupes qui
viennent de toutes les Caraïbes de
Jamaïque trinid Tobago du Royaume-Uni
aussi car il y a une grande communauté
afro dans ces pays tout ça c'est pour
enrichir notre
diaspora ça arrive qu'une seule fois par
an donc il faut qu'on en
profite au-delà de l'aspect culturel cet
événement une résonance mondiale on va
développer le tourisme au niveau
international
a tour de job de monter sur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
scène
[Musique]
SIM
merci merci c'était
super
[Musique]
ça t'a plu le spectacle oui et toi tu es
contente je suis très contente moi tant
que le public est heureux je suis
heureux
aussi ce soir on a lutté pour la culture
du peuple afro des Caraïbes on leur a
montré que ce sont des rois et qu'il y a
des talents uniques
ici c'était vraiment amusant quand je
vous regardais danser je me disais
qu'est-ce qu'es ont d'énergie et moi
quand j'étais perdu je regardais
simplement les
pas je suis juste très inspiré je suis
le rythme à partir de maintenant on va
pouvoir se connecter entre peuple des
Caraïbes on va se réunir et on va
grandir tous
ensemble
[Musique]